et on va plus loin avec le retour
désormais à nos côtés chaque jeudi d'
hamdam mostafavi directrice adjoint de
l'express bonjour jeu et mon retour
parmi nos âmes dames face à vous
gauthier rybinski chroniqueur
internationale ici même à france 24
la colère est loin de retomber en iran
depuis la mort d'une jeune femme
originaire du kurdistan iranien marsa à
mini arrêtés à téhéran pour un voile mal
positionné d'après l'a été depuis 1
d'après la télévision d'état au moins 17
personnes ont péri dans les
manifestations des ong parlent même d'au
moins 30 mans la répression s'étend
aussi aux réseaux sociaux l'accès à
instagram et what's app est suspendu
marc pop
face aux flammes les manifestants
savoure le spectacle dans les rues d'un
vol au nord de téhéran ce bureau d'un
gouverneur local brûle sous leurs yeux
depuis près d'une semaine un peu partout
en iran les habitants protestent contre
la mort d'une jeune femme après son
arrestation par la police des moeurs un
mouvement qui gagne de plus en plus
d'ampleur plusieurs grandes villes sont
touchées dont la capitale à téhéran un
commissariat a été incendié des slogans
hostiles au guide suprême l'ayatollah
ali khamenei ont été proférées
pour reprendre le contrôle de la
situation les autorités ont restreint
l'accès à internet et ainsi limiter la
coordination des manifestants selon la
télévision d'état et les ong locales
plusieurs personnes sont mortes la
diaspora iranienne à l'étranger elle
aussi se mobilise pour soutenir leurs
compatriotes
un blâme avec 17 morts un peut-être le
double 1,10 même certaines ong à un
retour en arrière est il encore possible
d'après vous bien maintenant le pouvoir
et est obligé finalement de donner des
gages à ces manifestants non le pouvoir
en iran n'est jamais obligé de rien ça
je vous le dis tout de suite ils ont
déjà connu énormément de mouvements de
protestation quand même ces dernières
années alors c'est vrai que là il faut
pas non plus négliger l'ampleur des
manifestations actuelles
même si
et ça reste assez difficile quand même
d'avoir des informations fiables et de
ça vraiment savoir combien de gens sont
mobilisés bon moi j'ai pu avoir au
téléphone des manifestants au kurdistan
en iran il ya quand même des centaines
voire des milliers de personnes dans les
rues il ya surtout ce tabou du hidjab
qui est tombée on voit ces jeunes femmes
qui le brûle qu'ils le sortent voilà
c'est quand même majeurs ce n'est pas
anodin et le pouvoir d'une certaine
manière on peut se dire est un peu
obligé de prendre ça en compte après les
iraniens ont quand même une capacité de
répression assez forte et
impressionnante qu'ils ont montré au
tour des années on parle de 17 mans mais
si ça se trouve c'est beaucoup plus ça
reste télévision d'état qu'il dit on
doit l'ag de la sarre on imagine plutôt
son intérêt à minimiser le chiffre
écouter ce que disait brillera ici le
président iranien hier à la tribune de
l'onu
mouly et snow remis la république
islamique d'iran considère que la
politique de deux poids deux mesures de
certains gouvernements l égard des
droits de l'homme est le facteur le plus
important de l'institutionnalisation de
la violation des droits de l'homme ce
qui a donné lieu à des prises de
positions diverses et variées à l'égard
d'un incident en faisant l'objet d'une
enquête en république islamique d'iran
et un silence de plomb sur le meurtre de
dizaines de femmes sans défense en un
court laps de temps dans l'un des pays
occidentaux
tant que cette politique de deux poids
deux mesures existera les droits de
l'homme ne seront pas à l'abri de
violations répétées les droits des
nations sont supérieurs aux droits de
l'homme et ils sont facilement piétiné
par des puissances oppressives
est-ce qu'il se rend vraiment service
le président iranien parce qu'on vient
d'entendre alors peut-être que la
traduction n'est pas parfaite même si
évidemment on exonère a volontiers notre
interprète mais enfin on a le sentiment
quand même d'un réel embarras dans
gauthier rybinski eux alors oui parce
que vous avez vu comment évoluera ici et
vite à chaque fois de nommer nommé le
pays en question dont on parle les
femmes qui ont été quittes y sont mortes
bon il ya cette gêne qui était quasiment
ridicule parce que à la fin de son
intervention il dit bien les droits des
nations sont supérieurs aux droits de
l'homme donc là la messe était dite si
josiah c'est à dire que voilà on est
face au régime qui sont
totalitaires semi totalitaire le droit
de la nation où le droit du chef passe
avant le le droit d des gens simplement
ski le ski le gêne je pense c'est que
comme vous disiez tout à l'heure il y a
d'abord ces mouvements spontanés je veux
dire c'est important de brûler le vous
le voile il tape c'est quelque chose de
symboliquement très fort ce qui est très
fort aussi c'est que me semble-t-il pour
la première fois les femmes sont
vraiment aux premières loges dans cette
affaire et que en plus de ça comparé
d'autres mouvements de révolte il ya eu
çà soit 2009 ça soit 2018 2019 2020 il y
à une revendication authentiquement
politique c'est à dire que sa porte
contre le régime contre khamenei alors
que précédemment c'était parfois
j'allais dire de manière latérale pas
frontale il y avait les autres questions
celle de par exemple l'inflation du de
la perte du pouvoir d'achat l'économie
est là on a le sentiment que cette
contestation se fige ce bloc au bon sens
du terme sur la nature même du régime
pour les iraniens et les iraniennes
hamdam mostafavi coupé aujourd'hui les
réseaux sociaux whatsapp instagram
sachant que la plupart ont déjà a été de
fait couper ces dernières années c'est
ça désorganise les manifestants au
contraire ça risque de renforcer
d'attiser leur colère évidemment de
manière pratique salle et désorganisent
un peu parce que c'est vrai que de ce
qu'on m'a dit ça sans gagner on le voit
bien avec les images sur les réseaux
sociaux ça s'organise beaucoup les lieux
de retrouvailles et c'est ça s'organise
beaucoup via les réseaux sociaux après
comme je dis parfois l'iran c'est une
nation de geeks qui sont capables de
détourner des tournées justement trouver
des vpn trouver comment se connecter et
se détourner des réseaux publics etc
avec pas mal de capacités ils ont
toujours un petit temps d'avancé sur le
régime donc c'est pas dit que ce soit ça
qui réussissent à répond elle semblait
une question subalterne en or elle et
elle ne l'est pas les
organiser clairement c'est comme ça
c'est de léry ans j'ai parlé avec un
manifestant qui était au kurdistan il
m'a dit on se retrouve grâce aux réseaux
sociaux c'est comme ça qu'on s'organise
donc évidemment c'est hyper important et
ce qui est important
je voudrais quand même revenir sur le
slogan comme disait gauthier c'est vrai
qu'il ya inscrit il ya deux slogans
important qui est mal bagdad olmert mort
au dictateur et j and jane et azadi ça
veut dire la liberté les femmes et la
vie en fait c'est la première fois qu'on
a ce lien aussi entre la liberté les
femmes qui vraiment et la démocratie
cc3c des éléments qui sont très forts
dans les manifestations qui s'expriment
très fortement et c'est vrai que on a pu
avoir des émeutes entre guillemets de la
fin on a pu avoir on avait en 2009 ce
grand mouvement contre la réélection
d'ahmadinejad mais c'est vrai que là on
est sur un pilier du régime vieux voilà
compte revenir et c'est pour mir hossein
moussavi mais là c'est vrai que c'est un
régime islamique et c'est un peu là où
le régime 1102 ligne rouge c'est à dire
que voilà ils sont pas prêts à céder sur
le voile parce que 6,7 sur le voile bas
et après c'est à dire que on peut mettre
un tel mouvement fait une telle
revendication d'émancipation gauthier
soul était noir sous part de l'éteignoir
ah oui
je suis d'accord enfin cédé sur sur le
voile c'est presque céder sur quelque
chose de d'intrinsec de fondamental à la
république islamique même si vous avez
un certain nombre de clercs qui disent
au fond le port du voile ne doit pas
être obligatoire il est très fortement
recommandée il ya toute une discussion
mais presque théologique sur la question
mais non mettre sous l'éteignoir ça
n'est pas possible en même temps ce
qu'on a vu dans les autres
contestation dans le dans les dernières
décennies c'est qu'elles sont fortement
réprimé et écraser est ce qu'aujourd'hui
cette conscience d'avoir à faire presque
à la jetée dire la dernière étape si
elle était franchie de manière vertueuse
b vous faites de s'attaquer à la nature
même du régime ça va donner quelque
chose qui ne sera plus des racines à bhl
comme vous ou suggérés dans votre
question c'est possible mais la capacité
de répression est énorme d'autant qu'en
plus vous savez très bien que le chef de
l'état ici 202 le président pardon est
quelqu'un qui a été très mal élu mais
qui s'en fiche un vont soulever des des
taux d'abstention qui lui même qui était
qui a supervisé lieu en 88 l'une des
plus grosses répression qui ait eu lieu
en iran et donc cédé pour lui ça n'a pas
de sens parce que le rapport de force
avec la population n'est pas quelque
chose de compris tu tout du moins dans
l'immédiat les états unis inflige des
sanctions à la police iranienne des
moeurs on a entendu d'ailleurs ces
derniers jours des membres même du
pouvoir un député
réclamé une enquête des as volé méthode
peut être même des sanctions ça peut
aller plus loin d'après voilà mostafavi
où elle est consubstantielle au régime
cette folie ce bon à rien une partie on
peut aussi interpréter le fait qu'une
partie des officiels iraniens pointe du
doigt la police des moeurs pour un peu
détourné le problème de la voilà en
disant mais c'est la police des moeurs
le problème c'est pas vraiment le régime
et c'est pas vraiment le voile donc il
faut toujours se méfier avec avec les
iraniens
et du coup
elle est l'avenir de cette police est
possible il est possible que des
sanctions soient prises ex terrain mais
pareil la police des moeurs ou les lames
la milice qui est de la ministe bassidji
ça aussi des éléments vraiment
fondamentaux durement réprimés pour le
coup les manifestants
09/06 lé d'imaginer que fondamentalement
il recule là dessus sans reculer sur sur
le reste et puisqu'il faut dire c'est
que ce gouvernement pourquoi aussi on en
arrive là c'est que ce gouvernement de
russie qui a été élu il ya un an et demi
à renforcer le contrôle sur les femmes
et à renforcer cette cette police des
moeurs parce que ça fait bon voilà les
iraniens ils ont toujours vécu avec le
voile mais dire voilà on voit dans les
photos que massa à mini elle portait son
voile sur sur l'arrière de la tête ça
c'est très courant je ne sais pas trop
particulièrement provoquant ça va jouer
ces tensions sur leur position dans les
négociations d'après vous très
rapidement gauthier ça franchement je ne
sais pas je bondis au point mort c'est
nul alors après c'est vrai que ça peut
jouer dans le sens où ça peut
convaincre le président qu'il faut
négocier avec les européens parce que
entre guillemets bah voila si la puce
sanctions économiques qui a une certaine
relâchement de ce côté là peut-être que
ça peut calmer la colère au sida
population d'un mauve le président est
tenu aussi par les gens auxquels ils
ajoutent qu'elle il doit quelque chose
mais ça soit les gardiens de la
révolution que le ca soit le système de
sécurité donc c'est toujours la même
histoire quelle que soit la volonté du
président il ya derrière ce qu'ils
peuvent le retenir par les bretelles en
disant non non tu ne va pas aussi loin
donc c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
dénué compliqué après vraiment une
enquête sur l'existence ou pas de la
shoah et en exigeant le voile pour la
journaliste de cnn christiane pourquoi
ne pas la nommer qui du coup a refusé
l'intérieur on comprend pour l'instant
en tout cas ils ne montrent pas une
image d'ouverture particulière sur le
fait international
autre actualité des pays occidentaux qui
dénoncent les uns après les autres les
menaces de vladimir poutine dernière en
date c'est emmanuel macron à qui
aujourd'hui parlent à nouveau de
chantage il faut dire que la russie
n'hésite plus à à désigner directement
les occidentaux comme deco belligérants
écouter sergueï lavrov aujourd'hui
nous n'avons aucun doute sur le fait que
l'ukraine est devenu un état totalement
totalitaire de type nazi où les normes
du droit humanitaire international sont
foulées aux pieds il n'est pas
surprenant que les forces armées
ukrainiennes et les bataillons nationaux
utilisent des tactiques de terroristes
en utilisant des civils pacifiques comme
boucliers humains et ce qui est
particulièrement cynique c'est la
position des états qui n'ont de
l'ukraine d'armes et équipements
militaires et qui entraînent leurs
soldats ligneuse mathieu cette politique
signifie que l'occident est directement
impliquée dans le conflit ukrainien et
qu'il est en fait une partie du conflit
les russes chantent ils en train
d'amener staff a dit moss travail de
créer les conditions d'un conflit
mondial ou bien se sont-ils tirer une
balle dans le pied si l'on en juge par
ces images de russes cherchant à fuir
leur pays ou manifestants alors une
moscou saint pétersbourg je vous
répondrai les deux rafael c'est à dire
que je pense que là on est quand même
dans une situation hyper dangereux
vraiment très dangereuse puisque là les
russes clairement jouent leur dernière 4
ils voient bien qu'ils arrivent pas
gagner en ukraine donc ils se disent si
on arrive à faire peur aux occidentaux
pour qu'ils arrêtent de soutenir les
ukrainiens là on va prendre l'aventage
de manière définitive donc même si
poutine a dit ce n'est pas du bluff pour
moi c'est un peu un bluff tout ça pour
pousser des occidentaux à se retirer en
crainte d'une escalade majeure qui peut
on tout voilà tout je pense quand même
que tout est possible et que tout peut
se produire après c'est sûr que c'est un
pari risqué d'avoir un peu à la
mobilisation parce qu'on voit que les
russes tant que c'était un confier à
l'extérieur de chez eux qui les
concernait pas vraiment et que c'était
ce à exalter la fierté nationale il
était ok mais là quand ça commence à
devoir faire partir là ça devient plus
compliqué on a l'impression qu'ils ont
lancé un train à toute allure devant un
mur et que maintenant il nous demande à
nous de la rep et d'une certaine manière
celle inverse souvenez de la blague ou
le train n'avançait pas et il y avait ce
talent inkisi de le faire marche etc et
brejnev arrivée il tire les rideaux et
10 et le train avance alors que le tran
à voir quoi hélas celle inverse a raison
il faut l'arrêter le train non alors
d'abord heureusement que le ridicule ne
tue pas parce que ça riait lavrov qui
dit le régime totalitaire est à kiev
mais ces gens là ont perdu tout sens de
la décence on aurait envie de rire si ce
n'était pas aussi grave il faut vraiment
être
je sais même pas si un quelqu'un comme
lavrov y croit en tout cas il est il est
dans la lignée c'est ça qui est le plus
grave par rapport à ce que dit poutine
sur la menace nucléaire c'est vrai qu'il
y a quelque chose qui relève un peu du
désarroi maintenant je ne pense pas que
l'occident a intérêt comme les
ukrainiens a soufflé ya trompeter sur le
désarroi des russes tout simplement
parce que c'est quelque chose qui peut
piquer encore plus poutine et que
al'inverse maintenir les positions et
faire avancer les ukrainiens c'est sans
doute ce qu'il ya de plus utile parce
que évidemment c'est bien que ces fameux
référendum du som fantoche qui sont
prévues deux jouent avant sans campagne
électorale vous allez voir que s'il ya
des observateurs ce sera tout un un
aréopage de militants d'extrême droite
de l'europe et qu'est ce que c'est fait
pourquoi pour créer des territoires
russe et dans ce cas ci il y à une
agression ou quelconque bataille et bien
la russie dira on grèce une partie
intégrante de la fédération de russie un
bon quand même sur l'occident qui s'est
quand même mis dans une position un
petit peu compliqué parce que c'est vrai
que c'est quand même difficile de livrer
des armes à l'ukraine et de soutenir
l'ukraine tout en disant mais on est pas
qu aux belligérants seo parce que c'est
sur ça que je vous la russie aussi c'est
à dire que les occidentaux se sont mis
dans une position impossible pour
réussir à négocier avec moscou on peut
pas soutenir aussi ouvertement un camp
donc ça c'est quand même une situation
un peu complexe pour les occidentaux
aujourd'hui qui sont entre le marteau et
l'enclume clairement si les russes
veulent à tout prix la guerre en
décrétant ces territoires territoire us
demain et donc les occidentaux comme
agresseur les occidentaux eux risquent
de devoir tôt ou tard définir leur
position merci beaucoup aimeraient au
moins c'est clair un footing dit c'est
la guerre et c'est une guerre de
civilisation c'est ce qu'on pense depuis
fort longtemps mais qui n'était pas lui
ou moins abat ses cartes cette fois ci
c'est clair merci gauthier s'était on va
plus loin avec hamdam mostafavi et
gauthier rybinski on se retrouve dans
moins de trois minutes pour un nouveau
journal dans pareil cas
[Musique]